we's those brows tweeze those brows yeah
my girlfriend tweeze is my eyebrows it's
like a weekly thing we do actually find
a really therapeutic I've never used one
of these usually I'm like oh it's this
move that out of the way I don't know
how this is done no this is fleek though
this is this is the fleek let's do this
cheers let's go
we've got stencils here my brother don't
look anything like this this is not good
this looks like anyways a lot out of it
I made just wing it and just do it
freehand brave I'm just gonna grab him
cold like it's what I'm good at
oh okay I mean little hairs here this is
actually kind of my bad oh oh geez it
hurts hmm okay that Matty I won't hurt I
was like a bigger hair I don't know how
I'm doing just like I don't know what
I'm gonna do with my life I feel like
I'm scared over here oh oh oh oh maybe
if I start getting like some of these
bigger hairs that are more
problematically
okay all my hair I got to do there and
problematically where you're here is
that you're playing down there here oh
yeah imma I don't feel like this is that
bad oh oh yeah another thing maybe oh
stop stop stop look pretty solid this is
I'm thinking sorry I look good yeah yeah
arch game are important I do feel a
little more glamorous I have two plans
now yeah look it looks like I've done
literally nothing and look this is
absurd oh I do have a tiny arch like
real that's cuz you're making it man you
make your arch this wasn't that painful
I think if guys are scared or anyone
scared of the pain it's really like
negligible yeah I don't think I'm gonna
tweeze my eyebrows again I mean at least
by myself
take your hairs ad out in the air like
confetti
that mine could be like it's too much
it's too much that's gross
here's all my Deana anybody want my Dean
oh it's yeah yeah I mean I got hairs too
guys if you need some Shelley DNA
[Music]